et sur le front diplomatique cette fois
intense activité ce jeudi réunion de
l'otan du g7 et de l'union européenne
dans cet ordre tout ça ce sera à
bruxelles triple saut mais vous
l'apercevez en présence également de joe
biden le président américain qui vient
renforcer la solidarité du camp
occidental
les précisions notre correspondante à
washington sonia dridi
c'est l'un des voyages présidentiels les
plus importants dans l'histoire
américaine récente titre cnn selon la
maison blanche cette visite du président
baden en europe a pour objectif de
consolider
l'incroyable unités je cite que les
états unis ont construit avec leurs
alliés en réponse à l'invasion russe la
mission de joe weise faire en sorte que
cette unité ne s'effiloche pas alors que
les défis sont nombreux le président
américain qui débute donc ce jeudi un
marathon diplomatique devrait annoncer
de nouvelles sanctions notamment contre
quelques 300 députés russes les états
unis veulent augmenter la pression sur
moscou et espèrent que leurs alliés
européens vont imposer également de
nouvelles sanctions l'administration
maiden qui se dit prête à aider l'europe
à réduire sa dépendance à l'énergie
russe est une priorité pour washington
et joe biden devrait s'exprimer sur le
sujet joe biden qui devrait également
pousser les alliés européens à faire
davantage front commun face à la chine
allié de la russie et enfin les états
unis pourraient annoncer de nouveau
déploiement militaire américain en
europe de l'est d'ailleurs le président
byden se rendra ce vendredi et ce samedi
en pologne où il va rendre visite aux
troupes américaines qui sont déployés
dans le pays le président by john qui va
également tenter de faire oublier à son
homologue polonais la sphère des mig-29
ses avions de chasse que varsovie
voulait faire livré à l'ukraine une
proposition rejetée par washington les
états unis disent vouloir éviter une
guerre directe avec moscou